les médias envoie toujours le même
message si on s'oppose à ce président et
bien ça signifie qu'on n'est pas
patriote et si on n'est pas patriote et
bien on est un danger une menace pour le
pays
Jones c'est la californienne qui nous
fait oublier
chartenegger grâce à vous voilà on
oublie ça va how are you Ricky ça va
très bien ah c'est tasmine non c'est pas
tasmine ça c'est tasmine bonsoir comment
tu vas très bien merci
bien donc c'est le premier album de
compo original depuis 7 ans et c'est un
en fait un album avec Killy Jones que
vous avez écrit un petit peu on dirait
grâce à George Bush parce que c'est un
petit peu en réaction à ce qu'il a fait
que vous avez écrit cet album
il y a une autre chanson qui s'appelle
patriote axe donc qui est contre les
axes qui sont des lois
voilà qui sont des lois d'exception donc
qui ont été votés aux États-Unis après
le 11 septembre et vous dites que ces
lois aux États-Unis en fait ont amené le
règne de l'arbitraire c'est-à-dire qu'il
n'y a plus de démocratie aux États-Unis
depuis le 11 septembre enfin depuis que
c'est lois ont été votées
ça ressemble beaucoup à la loi qui avait
été adoptée par les nazis en Allemagne
en 1938 on donne tout pouvoir au
gouvernement sous prétexte de protéger
contre le terrorisme et on a donc le
droit maintenant d'arrêter
un Américain ou que ce soit dans le
monde et si on vous arrête dans ces
conditions-là et bien on peut vous
détenir de manière arbitraire sans
avocat sans prévenir vos votre famille
sans vous dire pourquoi vous êtes arrêté
comme Guantanamo donc j'ai l'impression
que vraiment toutes les lois donc c'est
la fin de l'ABS corpus qui est quand
même la base du système juridique en
Angleterre et en Amérique absolument
alors vous dites qu'aujourd'hui aux
États-Unis finalement on finit par
confondre fascisme et patriotisme
je crois qu'on n'avait jamais été
bombardé vraiment sur notre territoire
et je crois que ce jour-là
je suis sortie je me suis promenée sur
la plage et très honnêtement j'ai pensé
que c'était la fin du monde
parce que moi je pensais qu'on irait
aller bombarder tout le monde en
représailles
mais on n'a pas fait ça finalement
je crois que
ceci m'a fait me rendre compte que je
pouvais mourir à n'importe quel moment
et je pourrais être sur un petit nuage
essayer de réfléchir à ma vie passée et
me dire pourquoi est-ce que j'ai eu si
peur pourquoi est-ce que je n'ai pas
fait plus de choses et donc j'ai décidé
à ce moment-là que à partir de
maintenant et ce pour le restant de ma
vie et bien je me battrai et j'essaierai
de sauver le monde pourquoi pas
[Applaudissements]
aux États-Unis les gens ont peur mais
ils ne savent pas de quoi et qu'il y a
une espèce de sentiment
vous savez la droite contrôle l'ensemble
des médias
[Musique]
contrôle l'essentiel de la radio
permanent l'essentiel des journaux et
puis Fox News vous connaissez
probablement la chaîne Fox
[Musique]
tout d'abord je crois que mon
inspiration me vient beaucoup des
chansons engagées de Marvin Gaye de
Christophe maéfield donc des chansons
engagées noires et ce qui m'a vraiment
inspiré c'est ce mouvement noir
cette c'est noir qui se sont vraiment
soulevées qui ont voulu se
défendre et c'est quelque chose qui m'a
beaucoup inspiré alors
que disait et ça m'a vraiment rappelé ce
que faisait bouche il a dit nous sommes
un pilier des libertés personnelles ici
en France et en vertu de cela et bien je
reprends toutes les libertés
personnelles des personnes à exprimer
leur religion
en fait
ils disent qu'ils veulent vous protéger
et en vertu de cela et bien il vous
Bafou toute vos libertés alors je ne
sais pas comment ça fonctionne
exactement en France mais je crois que
c'est très dangereux c'est très
dangereux de dire aux personnes qui
n'ont pas le droit de montrer leur
religion que ce soit avec une une croix
ou un voile si ils vont à l'école je
crois que c'est vraiment pas la faire du
gouvernement voilà
alors
les Killy Jones de tester un petit peu
la beatnique que vous étiez finalement à
l'époque où vous viviez dans
l'underground californien à Vineuil
quand vous avez rencontré comme wait
vous l'avez beaucoup aimé merci
et puis aussi un des cigarillos toujours
hein vous avez cigarillos
alors vous êtes venus à Paris en 1983 et
là il y a une chanson dans votre album
qui s'appelle Beach no strophy qui est
partiellement chanté en français est-ce
que vous parlez un petit peu le français
je sais pas français j'ai parlé pas
mieux français
regarde le temps
heureusement il y a tasmine oui alors
donc vous avez vécu en France quelques
temps en 1983
et aujourd'hui vous êtes contente de
retrouver la France
j'ai vécu de belles choses ici à un
moment vous vous êtes gravement plongé
dans la drogue je crois que c'est un
secret pour personne et vous n'êtes pas
la seule rassurez-vous vous avez pris
beau j'ai pris de l'héroïne pendant une
période de la cocaïne pendant une
période en parlant de la cocaïne vous
dites c'est la drogue du diable et je
voulais savoir comment vous êtes arrivés
à vous en sortir
[Musique]
et c'était les deux années où j'avais
beaucoup de succès et malheureusement
donc ça a été associé à mon nom alors
comment je m'en suis sortie et bien je
dirais que c'était vraiment au jour le
jour toute seule j'ai travaillé chaque
jour au quotidien
et je priais j'espérais que j'arriverai
à me reconstruire à comprendre pourquoi
j'en étais arrivé à me détruire moi-même
parce que je crois pas que les drogues
soient mal en soi mais je crois que
simplement certaines personnes ont
tendance à s'autodétruire à ce moment-là
elles vont utiliser soit des véhicules
soit de la drogue soit de l'alcool
donc ça c'est un petit peu ce que j'ai
appris j'ai appris à être courageuse
donner de l'amour et
j'espère en sorte que la vie de ma fille
soit meilleur que la mienne et puis me
rendre compte que ma vie avait vraiment
appris est-ce que vous êtes retourné
vers Dieu pour sortir de la drogue
pour échapper à Dieu
mais je parle avec Dieu tout le temps
que nous sommes vraiment entourés de
l'Esprit de Dieu
interview fait ou à faire
[Musique]
jouer de la musique à poil sur scène
fait ou à faire
tomber amoureuse de Tommy Lee Jones
ça c'est déjà fait
oublier les paroles sur scène fait ou à
faire
coucher avec votre meilleur ami eux fais
ou à faire
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
tube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu